a tough year for everyone including
performers here in las vegas
theaters on the strip have been dark now
for seven months
but this week the curtains finally go up
hector mejia is live inside the flamingo
he has given us a tour and he has some
details for us hi hector what are you
doing
hey there alex we've pretty much been
all over the place and uh you know
you're right it's been really tough for
the performers the stage crew
for these long seven months and finally
take a look they'll be able to
get these sites again and see this as
they walk back on stage and joining us
live
here we have pif the magic dragon and
pitfalls as they prepared to get back on
stage
now the show gets back on stage next
week they'll be welcoming audiences but
they're already here and you already
moved in
we already moved in that's right this is
where we put the cannon
uh and then i'm upstairs in marie's
dressing room that's where i live now
if you want to send me pizzas fifth
amazing dragon care of
marie's dress room flamingo tell us
about the changes
not only for the show but also in the
theater capacity is limited well as you
can see
it's a huge showroom the flamingo
showroom
but because we are socially distancing
then we can get up to a couple of
hundred people in here
everyone sits um at safe distances
within their own parties and everything
like that
the important thing is there is somebody
very clever in charge of it all
that is not me i just do what i'm told
okay
hand sanitizer stations wherever you go
or you can drink
now do you shoot hand sanitizer out of
this candy that's and that's what we
lubricate it with
that's why the dog goes so far don't you
buddy
that's it he's uh he has had a little
bit too much alcohol already this
morning
so tell us you know tell us a little bit
about the show well
over the last five years we've done a uh
a whole bunch of different tricks but
we've never been able to do like the big
stuff that we do on tour here in las
vegas
when we when we tour all over the world
we play like thousand seats two thousand
seas
these big theaters and now finally we
can do
a big show here in our home in las vegas
and show people uh uh show people how
big it gets with a tiny dog
and now you're able to be in this bigger
stage as you were just mentioning yeah
i love it here this is like this field
the flamingo has been our home here in
las vegas
for the last five years and um
uh hopefully we can we can uh stay in
this theater as long as donnie marie did
you know and uh that's pretty cool it's
pretty historic
it's incredible being being a part of
vegas history
here the fleming is one of the oldest
properties in las vegas
and um it's amazing having a home in the
heart of the vegas strip
and during the seven months you've been
able to uh sort of tweak the show and
make some changes
we actually been testing material for
the past seven months by doing virtual
shows
from the pifter magic dragon television
studio formerly known as my single car
garage
and uh so this material is all new
and people are loving it all over the
world and we're finally giving people a
chance to see
in person all right pif thank you so
much for having us
yeah let's do elbows yeah let's do
elbows let's do the other one
all right so the ticket's going still
starting today at 10 a.m
they're trying to find the owner of this
dog actually this dog is not even part
of the show at all
but we i don't know we just found it
here at the casino anyway
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys
hector did you get kicked out of the
dressing room
i did i did oh no well
it looked great while you were